every single thing that you just said is
untrue hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Frances Foster I'm Constance and
kissin and this is a show for you if
you're bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts
our brilliant guest this week is an
author journalist and social commentator
Melanie Phillips welcome to trigonometry
hello thank you for so much for having
me it's pleasure to have you here it's
been a while in the making this
interview it's great to finally get you
on the show for anyone who doesn't know
who you are which is not many people
these days but there are some I'm sure
tell everybody who are you how are you
where you are what has been an abridged
version of your journey through life oh
my goodness well I am currently a
columnist for The Times newspaper and I
write books and I do quite a lot of
broadcasting and a certain amount of
public speaking and I was known many
moons ago probably before you even
started to exist because I'm so very old
I was known to be a guardian Easter I
worked for the Guardian and the observer
for the best part of 20 years and for
the first period of that time I thought
that I was one of them and then I
realized rather crushingly that I wasn't
and from then on it was sort of downhill
all the way into a pit of infamy in
which I progressed to the Sunday Times
which was a kind of convalescent home
and then the Daily Mail which was a bit
like going from a convalescent home to
Mount Vesuvius in full eruptions
and then the larva washed me out of the
Daily Mail and I'm now very happily
ensconced at the Times which is
extremely civilized as a newspaper so
I've had quite a journey and my journey
through newspapers reflects my journey
politically to my former comrades on the
Left not that I ever thought I was the
left I thought I was a liberal I still
think I'm a liberal but in those days
when I worked for the Guardian I thought
that being a liberal and being left-wing
were pretty well the same thing and that
was not least because everyone used to
talk of themselves as the liberal left
and I thought being liberal was good and
being left was good and that we were all
marching under the same banner of
believing in truths as opposed to lies
and justice as opposed to injustice and
fairness and equality and the oppressed
against the oppressor and all those good
things and progress and reason
rationality and I still believe in all
those things but the break came when I
came to understand or believe that my
former comrades on the Left were on it
the exactly other side of all those
things well you started to use reason
and logic I did and and then I observed
to my complete horror that and to begin
with my complete perplexity that
literally like that the first column I
wrote which offended against the dogma
of the left I was immediately ostracized
I immediately became something that was
against the left and therefore had to be
the right and it took me a long time to
put a lot of stuff together and a long
time before I felt able to or ready to
leave what I consider to be my family my
political family but I did leave it
and have basically fought them ever
since and in response they never engage
in the arguments with me instead they
label me with increasing ly ferocious
labels in order to silence me so to
begin with I became was I became
right-wing overnight and then when I
didn't stop when I went further and
further issue by issue down this
terrible hill of infamy
I became far left and then ultra left
and then fascist and their Nazi which is
great since I'm a Jew and then they
discovered I was a Jew and I was the
wrong kind of Jew because I supported
Israel so then I became the madly could
Nick warmongering Zionist Jews kept
going I became deranged and insane so
then I became the deranged and insane
war mongering Nazi Zionist fascist Jew
and then it becomes quite difficult to
think what else they comes for at me so
that's basically the person you're
interviewing I think what you'd like to
know and all those titles are actually
great names for an Edinburgh show well
it's a pleasure to have another deranged
nothing to show we've got two of them
now on one show which is I'm sure a
rarity whenever we speak to people from
around different political positions my
sense of our sense to some extent now is
the kind of things that you talk about
the question I really want to ask you if
I dig really deep is are we living
through the last days of the Roman
Empire is that what's happening here
in terms of the West and the collapse of
the potential collapse of a civilization
is that where we are it's certainly how
I was stating the case no no no
understating it I think I've thought for
literally many years that this is a
civilization that's hurtling towards the
edge of the precipice without even
realizing there's a cliff it just
completely blind and I think that I
think what's been happening
I would say since the Second World War
we can talk about why I think that was a
major watershed I would go back further
and say I think that the First World War
was also a major watershed and I would
go back even further and say the seeds
of this were actually sown in the 18th
century enlightenment and have just
unraveled over the time but I would say
that certainly in the last 50 60 70
years it's been unraveling and I would
say it is a retreat from the or a
repudiation a lot of belief in the
fundamentals of Western modernity I
think that a profound demoralization set
in as a result of the Holocaust and the
second world war which occurred in the
very crucible very hard land of high
Western culture Germany was you know a
country which thought of itself as the
the sort of quintessence of reason and
progress and high culture you know they
all loved goethe and schiller and and
beethoven and you know they they played
people to the gas chambers to the tunes
of Mozart okay so the West knew that and
the West I think then was totally
demoralized if we could do that if
that's what Reason has done we've had it
with a reason and we've had it with the
nation-state because they believed the
story that they told themselves in the
West was that Hitler was a nationalist
and I think that was also
misunderstanding because Hitler wasn't a
nationalist Hitler despised people who
believed in the nation he thought they
were petty and silly and ridiculous he
was an imperialist he believed that he
was put on earth to recreate the Holy
Roman Empire which is a remainder
[Laughter]
that's not quite certainly wanted to
invade people and you know if Britain
hadn't been nationalist and you know so
really full of what it stood for where
both remain insinuate anything to do
that with Hitler but anyway I think that
that sort of set him a kind of
demoralization which made the sort of
governing bodies of the West the
political and intellectual bodies that
control our culture very vulnerable to a
whole series of anti Western nihilistic
destructive ideas which is where we are
now so you've mentioned these nihilistic
destructive ideas I mean very very dark
terms that you're using could you
pinpoint a couple of them that you think
are particularly destructive well yes I
mean the destruction of the traditional
family and destruction of the concept of
Education those two things education in
the family I think of what underpin our
society they give a society its shape
and I believe that the traditional
family of a mother and father bringing
up their children while not ideal in
every respect and in every circumstance
for sure is nevertheless broadly
speaking the best way to produce
emotionally healthy individuals who will
go on and you know do well in life and
we kind of got rid of all that because
we thought it was entirely wrong to have
a hierarchy of values entirely wrong to
have a hierarchy of family or any other
kind of cultural background because that
meant that people who weren't from that
background might feel would feel
disadvantaged put down and so on
so we we had a level playing field so no
family background could be privileged
and so the result I think has been
misery for unquantifiable numbers of
children and women in whose name it was
done so that's the first thing the
second thing with education and that was
where I first came to grief at the
Guardian the second column I wrote
saying maybe something's going wrong
with education it's not entirely the
fault of mrs. Thatcher and then the
world fell on me because of Fogle's
every bad thing was the fault of mrs.
Thatcher and the education world was
entirely blameless as you know as a
former teacher so but I charted over
those years in the late eighties I
charted in my journalism what I saw was
going on in education which I sort of
sat through all the debates and it was
mainly the educational hierarchy in
universities which was dictating this
and basically the the orthodoxy that
came out which you could not challenge
was that the very idea of education as a
means of transmitting a culture down
through the generations was inherently
illegitimate in the West because Western
culture was inherently racist and
colonialist so you must not transfer
transmit it down instead all these ideas
that went back to Rousseau and you know
let her child be free and the child
brings to the educational experience
what is infinitely superior to anything
the adult world can impose upon it so
you got rid of the idea of structures
and you let the child find its own way
in the world and the teacher became a
facilitator this mirror this may have
changed by the time you were a teacher I
don't know but probably got worse it got
worse so the teacher had a back seat the
teacher would not impart the teacher's
own knowledge
heaven forbid it should the teacher
should direct a child anywhere the
teacher would just stand back while the
children basically were left in my view
to stumble through a world without a map
and I thought that was just appalling
and I watched children being told that
they could read at the age of seven that
parents thought they could read and they
couldn't read they were guessing words
why were they being taught not taught to
read because teaching a child to read
involved a structure and a structure
involved progress at different levels
and that meant the son sure will be
faster at learning to read than other
children and that meant that the
children who was slower at learning to
read would have an identity problem for
the rest of their lives and would be
full of self-doubt so you'd have
nanostructure so
child was torturing it sounds ludicrous
that's what happened
and I read book after book theorizing
why this was the way forward so I
watched the education system be
destroyed as a system of transmitting a
culture and became something quite
different okay rather confused and over
the years subsequently it's gone back
and forward a bit there's been pulled
back it's been pulled forward again so
it's a bit of a mess
and to be flipped to be frank I haven't
followed it in that detail for some
years but that's what I wrote then and
so I thought then and I still think
those two things going down sort of laid
the groundwork and then you had this
whole business of following on from that
I mean these things are all based on the
idea that the individual is supreme
by the individual being supreme what was
meant was that what the individual
subjectively thought must take
precedence over any imposed Authority
from outside what I believed to be right
for me was right and nobody could tell
me that there was anything wrong in it
and that went not just for the
educational system not just for family
backgrounds it went for cultures so
heaven forbid suddenly that the West
could say to itself we're better than
other cultures so that what did that
mean what did that mean according to the
people who produce this doctrine it
meant that you have the brotherhood of
man it meant that because the West would
no longer look down on others therefore
everybody will be so happily so happily
involved in in nurturing each other in a
kind of brotherhood of man were all
friends and even Stevens together and
they have many prejudice bigotry excised
from the human heart and there were no
longer be war but what it also meant was
rather important that a liberal society
could not say that it was better than
any other so we couldn't say that we
stand for again the cardinal tenets of a
liberal society you know freedom of
expression freedom of religion equality
between men and women and all
the other stuff we couldn't say that was
better than any other so this is this is
the rotor disaster if a society can no
longer assert that it believes in its
values then it's over so and then all
these things led to other stuff and now
we've you know we're in a sort of this
you know the identity politics a bit
like the French Revolution onwards in
all revolutions eat their own so
identity politics and intersectionality
means that everyone's eating each other
so you know first of all we had you know
the gay rights movement and then we had
transgender and now gay is eating
transgender and transgender is eating
gay and it's like what so we've we're
descending all the time into evermore
widening circles absurdity and I think
damage and destruction so I've been
right about this for the you know
decades which is why it's a pleasure to
have you on and I was gonna identically
familiar with titanium ogród this
Twitter I am Andrew who's a good friend
of us he's the man behind that and he
paraphrase Ben Shapiro's quo which is
facts don't care about your feelings
into feelings don't care about your
facts that's right and this is what
you're really talking about this era of
subjectivity it is this essentially what
you're talking about is the erosion of
the concept of truth that's correct
the erosion of the idea that there is a
truth it can be measured that can be
observed that can be elucidated through
debate and discussion that's right and
that is the road to ruin shortly
absolutely I mean without truth you
can't have reason and without reason you
can't have modernity in the West and you
know here we have this tremendous
paradox that at a time when we pride
ourselves you know on as a society at
Western society
that this is the era of supreme
rationality and reasons so we're so
reasonable we're so rational we've done
without religion you know because we
think the religion is superstition it's
bunk and we're you know this is because
we are rational people we believe in the
intellect and you know we we think and
yet we've abolished the idea of
objective truth without which there's no
rationality so these things don't make
sense at all they don't add up first you
know not for a second and that is not
acknowledged either because the other
thing is that all these doctrines I've
been talking about because they are
associated so strongly with this idea
that this is the way we repair the world
we have been through this Cataclysm of
the Holocaust first world war Holocaust
war communism mass murder right we got
to avoid all that so we have to
eradicate war we have to eradicate
prejudice from the human heart we must
go forward as a global community of the
brotherhood of men and women fight so
who could possibly object because this
agenda of all these ideologies that are
to do with the perfection of the world
if anyone objects they are not just
wrong they are must be bad people
because they're objecting to the
perfection of the world there can be no
deviation from them therefore so again
the irony is that in an era which is so
supposedly rational but it's done away
with obscurantist religious belief this
is a religious belief it has all the
appurtenances not just a religious
belief but of what I would call
medieval apocalyptic Christian belief
when you know you had Dogma that
couldn't orthodoxes that couldn't be
gainsaid
you had heresy trials you had heretics
you had dissidents he had inquisitions
and then you had mass burning so we
don't have mass burnings anymore but
instead we destroy people's reputations
and their professional careers same
thing we cannot a bar as a society we've
created ideologies which cannot be
gainsaid
and anyone who does gainsay them is
consigned to various circles of hell and
so how do we push back against this
movement because you're insinuating that
it is a battle
[Laughter]
we're back where we started is it really
breaks it do you think well this is
complicated and it sounds absurd to say
bricks it because you know what's bricks
got to do with all this but I believe
that all the time I was writing out all
this stuff I was getting a lot of
support from the public all of whom I
could see you know they were higher in
hiding they were all being told that the
beliefs they had which contradicted all
these ideologies were not just wrong but
despicable they were despicable people
and then bricks it happened and I
thought ah seventeen point three million
people actually thinking like me because
not that they think like they thought
like me in every one of these issues but
broadly the underlying assumption of
what I would call the intellectual
political establishment which was to do
with this business of you know the
nation is basically a bad thing and the
the the idea of a culture being better
than any other is a bad thing and all
it's that sort of stuff and that anyone
who objects for that is an imbecile and
bigoted and the little Englander what
was David Cameron's famous phrase you
know fruitcakes
it wasn't racist because it racists and
all those people said you know what we
have a vote now to show that that's not
true because we want our country we want
to govern our country as an independent
nation because we believe in democracy
and we believe in governing our country
and we want to be able to have our own
culture expressed through our own laws
made by our own democratically elected
parliament which can't be overturned by
foreign a foreign court now I believe
that that was not in the front of
people's minds but that's basically what
they were on about and then so it breaks
it happened and I thought when I woke up
had to that morning I had two thoughts
one is that huh well what do you know
possibly Britain might survive after all
and my second thought was now it'll
never be allowed this would be a fight
to the death
that's my second thought and then I
didn't want to give you a seizure but
then the election of President Trump
happened and I thought the second shoe
has dropped because whatever you think
about President Trump as a person and I
have a number of reservations about him
to put it mildly what he stood for was
again the American people saying we
don't want what we are being told we
have to have a borderless country we
want our country we want to be able to
say that America stands for something
which we will defend and we will welcome
people in but we have to be a country
under the law we cannot have this mass
law breaking on the basis that there
shouldn't be any border laws because
we're all a brotherhood of men and they
were called racist and red rednecks and
bigots and they elected their guy and
then in Europe the entire political
establishment has agreed for decades
that the nation is the source of
everything that went wrong in Europe the
entire establishment and so the people
of Europe were told you wonder have your
own culture that's that's that's the
road to Nazism no you will have what we
will give you and guess what they're
voting for populist parties some of
which in my view are simply parties
which are saying you know what we just
want to have our own culture back and
some of the month are obnoxious they are
racist they come from you know they have
not seen or fascist pasts and it's a
mess but it's because the people have no
alternative so you have those three
things happening which I believe signify
a great movement of the people not
unified lis by no means unified ly on
the contrary there is great fights going
on as here of a brexit blah blah Trump
totally divisive but it's a fight now
that wasn't in existence before there is
a fight on between two sides one is
basically
crow the basic ideas of the West and the
other is not that's an exaggeration and
there are people who want a bit of both
and I don't want to imply that people
are you know totally on one side or
totally on the other side but that's
broadly how I see it so there is a kind
of [ __ ] of light except that battle is
joined and who knows how it's going to
end and it could become extremely messy
and could become violent no but messy
inter sense of violent oh really it's
already violent in parts in on the
continent of Europe
already and I've my fear is that that's
going to get worse because this this
this great civilization or division
which is now opened up it's very hard to
see how it can be how it can be joined
up it is a proper division between
different ways of looking at the world I
see a lot in what you're saying
particularly on the national identity
sounds because one of the things that
you know I'm originally from Russia but
I've lived here for a long time so I can
kind of see things from both
perspectives one of the things I was
find quite shocking about some British
people is the level of embarrassment
they have about their own national
identity they don't I'd this idea that
this country is somehow evil and bad and
and they have to be embarrassed for
being but they have to apologize in a
very British way for being British and
I've always found that a very strange
thing for a nation to embrace well you
know the joke was another joke about you
know if you're British and someone
treads on your foot you say I'm so sorry
I mean that's what the British do we
apologise but I think the whole of the
whole of the West has been imbued by
this idea that we have kind of we've
been born into original sin the original
sin of colonialism the original sin of
empire the original sin of slavery as if
we invented it all you know and in a way
that's see one of my main quarrels with
the left is that they are so racist
they say insist on
perceiving the world through the prism
of their own cultural beliefs so this
idea of you know being being the
originators of things like slavery well
it's simply not true and also this idea
that everyone in the world is basically
reasonable we are so reasonable because
we are the Acne of reason and it's like
an imposition so you know we we
collectively in the West don't even try
to understand cultures which are
completely different as we will not have
it there they're different they have to
be the same as us we have to see them
through the prism of us because we carry
everything before us to me I find that
so at the very least patronizing but I
believe it to be racist fundamentally
racist that it's not that we're that we
in the West think we're so much better
than everybody else
we think that nobody else can be any
different from us it's not possible
because we are just you know what we
stand for is self-evidently wonderful
and do you not think as well and I think
you touched on it we sort of the culture
of individualism versus a culture of the
community because the Liberals are hyper
individualistic if you really look at
any politics it's about separating
people and you know you often say people
who vote to remain I could go and live
and work in 27 other countries around
the world most people don't want that
most people just want to stay and live
and work within their own communities a
certain number of people do but the
majority of people do not want it I
couldn't agree with you more people it's
it's it's sort of almost a universal
condition people need to feel that they
belong they need to feel rooted and they
want to feel rooted they want to feel
that they have can have families in
safety and that they have other than
that they feel they would feel rooted in
the community and then in the larger
community which is a nation in which
they make common cause with others so
that they feel safe they identify they
they belong
now there's a whole bunch of people who
I think have have grown up in recent
decades who are who don't live like that
they their lives are much more
internationalist and they tend to be
people who have higher education and
very very good jobs and they work for
multinational companies or they work in
multinational arena and they travel a
very great deal and they believe
themselves to be citizens of the world
because they don't have an allegiance to
a locality why should they they didn't
need it whereas everybody else does need
it and they look down on the people who
need it and they consider that to be
racist well it's not racist it's just
human nature to be like that so I think
that does explain quite a lot of the
division unfortunately but again it's
it's a very unpleasant attitude that you
know anyone who's not like me this is
this upper class is an inferior being
they're racist they're bigots they're
rednecks they're imbeciles excuse me
and it's also as well that sort of hyper
liberal liberalism that individualism
which I'm admit I'm that type of person
I'm very I see that's how I see myself
whatever else it doesn't make you happy
the connections that actually make you
happy are the connections with your
friends your family the people that you
surround yourself with the comfort you
take from seeing your family it's not
really an achievements or traveling
around the world for me looks great on
Facebook but it's not it well I think
there's a lot of unhappiness around
because I think again we've told
ourselves collectively to believe in a
chimera
which is happy you know happiness is the
is the aim everything is to make us
happy and the more we try and make
ourselves happy the unhappy we become
because I believe there are there's
something that's been that's more
important to us than happiness more
fundamental which sounds pompous but I
believe it to be true which is a meaning
to life and if you have no meaning to
your life if you believe you know you're
a random
purposeless atom you know it's an
accidental combination of synapses which
happens to be whirling around this
particular point in time and your only
function in life is to sort of find
stuff to have and possess and make
yourself happy it's all pointless and so
you don't become happy at all and it
sounds awful but to say this but you
know the habit happen true happiness
offers often comes from from it sounds
so pious to say this but happiness comes
from other people it comes from you know
being nice to and doing good to other
people and looking out for other people
before yourself and we're living in such
a virtue signalling world where we're
all sort of you know wearing our our
moral virtue on our sleeves but it's all
part it's all meaningless it's all stuff
that doesn't actually concern us it
doesn't give us it doesn't it doesn't
require anything from us necessarily and
it's the people who don't go around
wearing it on their sleeve we just get
on with life by looking after each other
I'm putting others first really putting
others first that's where I think a much
greater sense of purpose in life
and much greater sense of satisfaction
and ability to accept stuff as it is
which is I think the source of
tranquillity which a lot of people just
don't have they don't have tranquillity
and ironically what you're saying is
tied into Judo judeo-christian values
I'm glad you mentioned that I mean this
is the irony that the things that we as
a secular society tell ourselves that we
value like putting others first
conscience and compassion and fairness
and justice and truth we pay lip service
to all these things and we tell
ourselves that it's only because we've
got rid of religion that we have all
these things and the people who are
religious want to reverse all that they
want to put us all in Chains and they're
obscurantist they don't have we
and it's just so completely the opposite
of the truth because I want to give my
liberal friends total apoplexy I say
what I believe to be the case that
reason and compassion
both were given to us in the Hebrew
Bible I mean I am a Jew and that that
was disseminated through the West
through Christianity until the Hebrew
Bible came along we didn't have a
rational universe I mean the Hebrew
Bible is predicated on the idea that
there is a purpose to the universe that
there was an intelligent creator and
that therefore there are natural laws
which can be interrogated by people we
call scientists that was the beginning
of science in the West it's also had the
revolutionary idea of a linear narrative
of history as opposed to the world going
round around in circles
hence the West has progressed hence the
West her science
hence the West has reason without the
Hebrew Bible and the Christianity that
gave it expression in the West who
wouldn't have those things the West
wouldn't be the West my liberal friends
don't like me sing absolute they start
talking about the Greeks what I mean a
Greeks were great guys they did a lot
you know what did the Romans ever do for
us but anyway the Greeks did a lot but
you know so getting rid of
judeo-christian stuff is not getting rid
of obscurantism
and rubbish and imbecility it's inviting
it in well whether you believe in God or
not do you you can't not acknowledge
that our civilization is based on those
values of Judea creepy people do I know
I mean it's crazy what you can you can
not be a religious person yourself as I
am not absolutely not absolutely but the
truth is still the truth this Eisley but
this is problematic now of course it's
very problematic people don't people
cannot cannot accept what you've just
said you know if if you don't believe in
God and it's all rubbish and you can't
sort of not believe but realize that
that's what lies underneath
the things that we value as you've just
said that minutes and is that because
it's exclusionary to other religious
group so what is the logic behind non
acknowledging this kind of fundamental
no I think it's that we've made a god of
materialism that we have told ourselves
that what we see is all there is that
what it then you know that the only the
things that have a corporeal existence
are real that everything else is a
fiction the Flying Spaghetti Monster as
Professor Dawkins put it but when you
look at a lot of science and I'm not a
scientist and I'm open to the accusation
that you know I did or I'm talking about
I'm not a scientist but as I've been
given to understand by scientists who I
do respect very much a lot of physics in
particular and other sorts of science
they are a kind of you know there is the
the idea that there is stuff that
actually proves it all isn't the way
science works it works through
hypothesis and falsification and
challenge and so on and a lot of the
physics that has emerged in recent years
is you could say a species of faith
because it is a leap it's a it's a it's
it's a hypothesis so the distinction
between faith and science I think is a
false one I think that a particular kind
of faith gave rise to science and
science in certain respects has come in
recent years to believe that there is
something that that there is a an
element to existence which science not
only doesn't yet have the ability to
read them out but we'll never fed them
out now I'm not saying that's what I'm
hearing scientists say well the
conspiracy theorists on the Internet are
gonna be happy the Jews are behind it
all laughter hi guys we're very excited
to announce that trigonometry that we've
got a new sponsor now some of you might
be wondering with constant is very sadly
he has unfortunately been deported
breaks it means breaks it no I'm joking
he obviously hasn't been deported he's
been sent to the USA to help
the trial now thanks to our friends at
b-52 comm you get the opportunity to
sample eight beers absolutely free all
you need to do is go to WWE to comm
forward slash trigger and pay for pound
nine to five for postage and packaging
and it's all yours so that's a word beer
followed by the numbers five and to.com
forward slash trigger b-52 a global
pioneers when it comes to beer they
traveled the world tasting and something
the best beers small batch breweries
have to offer things have included
Germany Korea Norway Finland and
California which isn't a country the
beauty of b-52 is they don't hold you to
ransom so you can leave anytime you want
all you have to do is go to WWE to calm
forward-slash trigger to claim your
eight free beers plus if you mentioned
the show you will get an extra two free
beers which means you'll be able to get
drunk on your own
watching trigonometry like an absolute
legend so all you have to do is go to
WWE to calm forward-slash trigger
[Music]
speaking of the Jews we haven't pissed
off enough people so let's talk about
Israel because you you have some pretty
strong bees I heard a number of talks
that you gave on the subject and it's
something that I think it's probably
fair to say we don't really know much
about no it doesn't stop me from
tweeting it's very difficult to talk
about it especially if you don't know
anything about it but the fundamental
narrative about Israel essentially is
that as a compensation for the Holocaust
the Jews were given a piece of someone
else's land in the Middle East where
they've settled and now there is a
battle over that piece of land because
of that original sin if you like which
is a viewpoint of Frank
up until I started listening to some of
you to your talks
it was unshakable in my really
understand yeah absolutely but I think
because I don't know I honestly don't
narrative yeah yeah so is in what way is
that not the case Melanie every single
thing that you just said is untrue most
of your conversation was is a big
subject but the idea that the Jews had
no connection to the Land of Israel
until a guilt ridden West took them out
as a remnant of the Holocaust and stuck
them into someone else's country is the
opposite of the truth so what is the
truth the Jews are the only people for
whom the Land of Israel was ever there
National Kingdom hundreds and hundreds
of years before Islam was even invented
and before the Arabs invaded the Jews
were the original nation the original
nation upon which America and Britain in
a kind of mystical fashion in Britain
modeled themselves why do I say that
they were a nation because they were a
people in a particular area of land
which they governed according to laws
they made and which they defended now
they were a nation for several hundred
years under various kings and then they
were basically kicked out and they
didn't they returned they kicked out
again and then the that land of Israel
was occupied by vast numbers of
different civilizations the Romans the
Assyrians the Arabs various various
sorts of Muslims Christians Crusaders
and for a long period the Ottoman Turks
who were Muslim but not Arab and then we
get to the turn of the last century
and there grew up in Britain as a result
of mainly as a relative evangelical
Christianity a movement to return the
Jews to their ancestral homeland and
these people call Christian Zionists and
the kind of apogee of Christian Zionism
in political terms was the Balfour
Declaration 1917 was a cabinet which was
dominated by Christian Zionists and they
believed that it was their duty to help
the Jews return to risk restore their
ancient homeland
long story short as you will know after
the first world war the entire Middle
East was carved up between Britain and
France which you know itself was a
questionable activity and they create
straight lines on the map yes it's
slightly more complicated so you know
some of these countries that they
created you know you could say oh that's
very questionable but basically the
precursor of the United Nations which
was then the League of Nations in the
1920s decided that as a matter of
international treaty obligation Britain
would be given custodianship of what was
then called Palestine a name given to it
insultingly by the Romans in order to
erase its Jewish identity the British
will be given custodianship of Palestine
called the mandate under which Britain
would be under a binding treaty
obligation to return the Jews to their
ancestral homeland decree created now
what was Palestine at the time well a
bit of it a very large chunk of it was
promptly given away to the Arabs by
Winston Churchill to become Transjordan
which is now Jordan so what did that
leave as the territory within which
Britain had a binding duty undertaken by
the world body of the time to return the
Jews as a matter of historic right what
was that territory it is what is now
Israel what is called the West Bank and
Gaza that is the territory to which the
Jews alone were given the right to
turn because they alone had ruled it
terms which have never been abrogated
even though the League of Nations is no
more it gave rise to the United Nations
but the United Nations took on in its
Charter it took on all the obligations
of its predecessor unless they were
specifically abrogated those terms have
never been abrogated so what then
happened was although the Arabs of the
time around 1917 1918 King Faisal
notably and one or two others they said
welcome we welcome back the Jews to
their ancestral homeland they used this
term because it was in their own
religion they knew this was a Jewish
homeland and then a lot of stuff
happened basically the British having
undertaken in the first place this duty
to settle the Jews in their ancestral
homeland the Jew the the British
colonial office at the time and the
colonial administrators who were put
into Palestine to administer this
mandate did everything they could to
stop it and they among other things
brought in a an Islamic firebrand this
was at the time when Islamism as we know
it political Islam was growing it was
reinvented after the first world war and
they brought in the British brought in a
particular Islamic firebrand called Haj
Amin al-husseini as the Grand Mufti of
Jerusalem and he incited he was brought
in to incite revolt and he did there
were then pogroms after pogroms after
pogroms of the returning Jews and the
thing then blew up into thora
three-sided war Jews and Arabs and
British all basically at various times
all fighting each other
scroll on the British threw in the towel
gave it over to the United Nations the
United States whether Britain had
Britain by this time had reneged on its
obligation to settle the Jews in the
land Britain had decided the only way to
solve this was to give
a portion of this land to the Arabs in
order to shut them up and stop them from
fighting and in accordance with that the
British closed the gates of Palestine at
the time when the Jews were starting to
be exterminated in Europe that's what
happened and then the United Nations
took over the war finished the other
nations took over United Nations said
just like Britain had said right two
states two-state solution one for Jews
one for the Arabs and just as with every
and every occasion since then the Jews
said what you're gonna take this away
from us fine fine
give us anything anything because we're
desperate and the Arab said what Jews
here never
and they invaded or they went to war
against the Jewish homeland there was a
what's called the War of Independence
which amazingly the Jews won against all
the odds subsequently there have been I
forgotten how many two three four
offers of a state of Palestine to the
Arabs which are he made by Israel at
every occasion the Arabs are refused and
have gone to war or have stepped up
terrorist activity against Israelis now
before we go any further into that part
of it I just want to come back to this
homeland idea this idea that many many
centuries ago a certainly if we strip
away their identities and we just go
many many moons ago a certain group of
people had a kingdom in this area and
after that there have been ten
civilizations or 15 civilizations that
have come and lived in this land and now
for some reason is its clique I know I
mean isn't it a bit like me going well I
used to you know I grew up in this flan
in Moscow and now I want to be resettled
there and all the neighbors have agreed
to kick out that guy who lives there now
and put me in that place well no it's
not like that first of all the Jews
never left the land they were always
coming back to it even under occupation
there was always a Jewish presence in
the land and from the mid 19th century
onwards there was a Jewish majority in
Jerusalem
that's the first thing the second thing
was that the land at the time of the
mandate was very sparsely populated the
people who were there were mainly
nomadic Arabs but they didn't have an
identity they were they considered
themselves to be part of Syria which was
created or Bedouin they were they there
was no such thing as Palestinians
Palestinians were the Jews but there
were people who lived there they yes and
then because the Jews started coming
back Arab started Arabs and others
started pouring in from neighbouring
Arab lands and the British then let let
them come in even though they were many
of them illegal immigrants but they let
them come in because they wanted to stop
the Jewish homeland so it's not a
question of kicking people out it's a
it's aids and it's not a question of you
know people who had some sort of
mystical attachment to some country
you're talking about the Jewish people
who have been persecuted in virtually
every country that in which they've
settled no country ever ever wanted them
apart from India and China which have
never had a problem with the Jewish
population it's been in Europe no way
nobody wanted them and it was in respect
of that as well as the fact that they
were the original nation and have always
wanted to go back that they were
considered to have the right to go back
so so is this kind of perpetual
persecution what I I'm just trying to
get this logically clear but it's all
persecution of Jews in Europe is that
what uniquely in the history of humanity
gives choose the right to resettle a
land in which they didn't have that much
of a present no it was a country but a
long time ago okay so why do people
think that if they think that it was the
Palestinians country a long time ago
that's that means that they should have
it but they were living there in the
19th century but they weren't there was
no such thing as the Palestinians there
was no such thing as the Palestinian
people there was no power
people until it was invented in the
mid-1960s there was these nomadic Arabs
who lived there but they didn't want a
country their own the Jews were a nation
they had a country of their own and it
was taken away from them and then they
were persecuted around the world and so
it seemed the only decent and fair that
they should have it back and a lot of
people at the time thought that was
absolutely fine but it will see a
resistance whipped up which was
basically a religious resistance in my
view and remains basically a religious
resistance because if you look at the
Arab world the Muslim world
unfortunately and look at the
Palestinian Arabs and what they are
producing day by day in terms of what
they teach their children and the
materials they put out it's it's not
it's not really accurate just to say
it's anti-israel which it is and it's
it's certainly the case that they want
in my view and I think this is proven by
what they say and what they do and their
insignia in their flags and their
materials they want Israel gone they
don't want to stay so they want is well
gone but it's much worse than that
what they're producing day by day is is
anti-jewish venom crude conspiratorial
Jews are uniquely the source of evil in
the world that's what they're producing
that's where they're teaching their
children to hate and people in the West
just have no idea of this because it is
never ever reported and so I got into a
lot of difficulty because until the year
2000 I'd never been into Israel never
wanted to go I thought there's a British
Jew I was you know it was it was great
it was fine I mean nothing to do with me
and I'd bought into quite a lot of the
stuff but you know we've been talking
about because you know if you don't know
about the Middle East
why would you think I need any
difference and in in in 1982 when I was
at the Guardian
I was brought up very sharply against
the fact that as a British Jew I spoke
as a matter of fairness about why there
seemed to be a double standard in the
reporting of Israel at that time as
opposed to reporting of Syria Syria at
that time had murdered or caused to be
killed
between 15 and 40 thousand opponents of
President Assad the father of President
Assad and it was virtually not reported
at the garden it was a few paragraphs it
was there's nothing where as Israel was
at war in the Lebanon and it was a
front-page story every day it was
furious editorials it was outrage or
Paes and I said why is there a level
standard and that's when I realized the
racism of the left because I was told of
course there's a double standard you
don't expect us to treat the developing
world like us the developing world has
not brought up as we are to respect
human life
consequently we can't judge them by our
standards that's racism I went what so
let me get this right if someone's born
into the developing world they're not
entitled to the same rights to life and
liberty as we are isn't that racism and
they said why you so upset you redo you
the great honor I became you mm-hmm like
that you we do you the great honor of
assuming that you and Israel and I
became Israel that you in Israel adhere
to the same principles as we do respect
for human life
so we judge you by our standards and
what's more you tell us that you are
morally superior to us
so we should judge you by higher
standards and that's when I realized the
anti-semitism of the left and the racism
of the left and that's when I first
realized that my naive belief that we
were all marching to the same tube
behind the same banner of decency was
not the case they were on the other side
and then I didn't do any more stuff
about any of that for a long time and
then in the year 2000 when the Intifada
started Second Intifada that was called
something very similar happened
Israelis are being blown to bits in
pizza parlors and cafes and Bob buses in
Israel and you know several thousand
were murdered and from the get-go in
Britain Israel was totally condemned for
taking condign action to stop it and as
a matter of justice and fairness I said
what is this why are you behaving like
this and everybody went oh she's a Jew
she's not properly British and that was
when I realized as a British you you
could not support the Jewish people as a
people not allowed and that's what I
realized something was very very badly
wrong with Britain's attitude to Jews
not just to Israel but to Jews and that
those two were bound up together because
Israel was being presented not least by
the BBC as basically the fount of all
evil in the Middle East it was an
aggressive country it behaved illegally
all of this in my view as I came to
believe over many years subsequently all
of it was a lie but that's what everyone
was told and so consequently if you were
a Jew standing up for all this and of
course you were also evil of course you
were and this was a shattering really
shattering set of developments for me
and eventually cut long story short or
shorter I came to put all that together
with all the other stuff we're talking
about all the other stuff we're talking
about because it's all to do with as you
said Constantine truth and lies it's
basically what it's about when you pair
it all down people are telling them
sells lies about reality they're living
in a world of fantasy which they purport
that they they want us to believe is the
reality they tell lies about other
people and they don't realize that their
lies because there's no such thing as a
lion woods there's no such thing as
truth everything is a matter of opinion
everything is a matter of opinion so you
can't ever win an argument so all these
things it seemed to me I'm you know
syncopating a lot of stuff it's a big
topic topic I want to ask you something
Bantu Semitism because I know you one of
your books deals one of your recent
books with that
actually I wasn't gonna talk about it
just yet
but I wanted to ask you about Jews in
general and why is it the Jews we're not
really part of this progressive stack as
they call it we're not we're not
oppressed in the same way in this view
of the world oh yes we're all upper
you're a woman therefore you're
oppressed more than two comma Jews it
does some raps even got you know as you
mentioned earlier I think historically
certainly one of the most oppressed
minorities in the history of humanity
absolutely the most persecuted so why
why don't we get the credit so time
we're so tiny yes
you know we're such a tiny number so I
want my oppression points I've won mine
see diversity you know they need a
Jewish Nazi on the BBC you Constantine
you obviously you just don't realize
Jews run the world
oh yes the banks they run the Lord
they run medicine they're into
everything this is the default position
Jews cannot be victims because Jews are
powerful why are they powerful because
they are behind capitalism this is how
this is how this is how the thinking is
so you have the most persecuted people
on earth who are the most powerful
people on earth and this is the thing
about anti-semitism it simultaneously
treats Jews as lower than animals and as
the most supernaturally powerful force
ever known in the history of mankind
simultaneously the most powerful and the
most animalistic and useless
simultaneously there is no prejudice
like it so I'm afraid that the whole
intersectionality thing and the whole
anti-israel thing is based fundamentally
on anti-semitism big caveat that does
not mean that people who think Israel is
disgusting are necessarily anti-semites
to me an anti-semite you have you know I
can't look into people's souls and
understand what's motivating them and
it's perfectly possible to believe all
the garbage about Israel and you know
not not believe that Jews are awful
people but what I'm saying is that the
discourse about Israel is fundamentally
anti-jew because there is no other
country people or cause in the world
that has ever been subjected to this
level of obsessional hysterical
vilification based on entirely on
falsehoods and which elevates israel
just like the Jews have always been
elevated in anti-semitic discourse since
time immemorial as being the world's
single most evil or destructive or
harmful entity exactly the same
characteristics that applied to
traditional anti-semitism which are
unique to it are applied to the
treatment of Israel and it's not a
coincidence do you think this let me
just finish the Jew stuff Internet but I
just want to finish this thing because
Jews are successful but as a group
comparatively to other groups I think
that is probably fair to say
statistically speaking and you look at
what's happening to Asians in America in
terms of Harvard and I don't know if you
followed the story basically very people
who have a high SAT score in America
a disproportionately Asian
chinese-american of japanese-americans
and they get discriminated against yes
yes in AB applying for university so is
it more than just as a successful
minority you don't fit the narrative of
intersectionalities is that maybe why
why that that we don't fit the narrative
and therefore we're not included in the
oppression metrics well but you
mentioned you know Asians they're
included well Japanese and Chinese
probably not so much not so much no but
they're not excluded I mean they're not
given the firm ative actions what I'm
saying right I'm certainly in American
universities for example punished in
fact for being yes yes there is there is
yes Cyrus there is something about that
and with Jews it's even more so because
the the disproportion between the the
tiny number of Jewish persons and their
achievements yeah in a bell prizewinners
is I think I'm right in saying it's more
extreme the disproportionate is more
extreme than anyone else so there is
more there is more resentment I would
say it's I mean I would say it's
resentment I wouldn't say it's simply
that oh well you know we don't have to
look after them so they're out there
they're alright it's more a resentment
because I hear it I hit the whole time
you know Jews are controlling they're
controlling the banks they're
controlling capitalism they're
controlling the media I hear it the
whole time it's definitely what happens
on this podcast meet controlling
everything go for it I was a couple of
questions number one would you say that
anti-semitism is on the rise I have
friends who are Jewish and state that
and stated openly in state in particular
on the left there is become more open
and people were actually now feel more
liberated to say anti-semitic things
definitely definitely
i I think I mean I I do get a bit
impatient because I think you know I've
thought this for a long time
and it's only really since Jeremy Corbyn
came to power in the Labor Party that
it's become a thing that's been talked
about
if one talked about tries to work
anti-semitism on the left previously we
were people like me
in fact probably just me I think I can't
think of anybody else who were saying it
but I was told you know you're waving
the Shroud of the Holocaust to sanitize
the crimes of Israel excuse me
okay and that's because the whole
business of Israel was always wrapped up
in this and a lot of it you know it was
very hard to separate it out and then
Jeremy Corbyn came on the scene and then
the whole thing exploded in the Labor
Party as an issue
and then in the way that I'm sure that
that you know and as a result of all of
that people have felt emboldened because
nothing's been done to put these people
back behind under the underneath their
stone people become increasingly
emboldened to say stuff which would have
been not said so openly just a few years
ago but it's been there it's been
building for a long time and I believe
it's intimately connected with Israel
and support for the Palestinians because
if you're supporting people who are in
the private Palestinians who are saying
we came weak out the Jews control
everything they are the source of evil
in the world
they control capitalism they control the
banks they control American foreign
policy then why he was so surprised when
people in the Labor Party say it when
they're supporting that I remember when
the Iraq war happened he wrote what was
not exactly uncontroversial but I
remember I remember being told it's a
conspiracy between tel-aviv and oh
that's Jerusalem and Washington to put
our boys at risk it's completely untrue
but Jewish conspiracy had to be had to
be
and that was openly said openly said by
all kinds of people and my Kurt this is
a moment this goes this my grandfather
was originally Bernice and he was firmly
anti-israel and particular very upset
with Israel's treatment of Lebanon did
he not have some some reason to be upset
by Israeli behavior this was when this
was well he's passed away now but this
was particularly in the 60s and the 70s
and how he was talking about how Lebanon
was his French essentially leveled in
particular Beirut I'm not sure about the
60s and 70s yeah but I remember the
eighties Isis 8 the 82 you know invasion
of Lebanon and that was because it was
being used as the as the base for the
PLO in order to continue to try and
annihilate Israel
so yes Lebanon got badly badly used but
Lebanon you know had become
unfortunately as it still is the landing
ground for a genocidal war and now it's
even much much worse much much worse
there are something like 140 160 hundred
140,000 minimum missiles pointing at
Israel embedded in Lebanon in people's
apartments underneath their apartments
in their apartment blocks the whole of
the population is hostage so that if
Israel wants to stop its own
annihilation it has to flatten Lebanon
that's the situation now whose fault is
that
that is reals fault how would you feel
if Britain had one missile pointing at
it from Wales there's 150 hundred and
forty thousand missiles which can cover
the whole of Israel like less like a
missile per sheep and well oh well you
know the Israelis you know I mean
I mean after all what right of the Jews
have to that Latin anyway I mean you
know they got rid of the indigenous
population really really that's the
level of this discussion that goes on
the whole time no one in this country
has any idea about what I've just said
about 140,000 listen miles
no one cares if one were to say Britain
guess what 140,000 missiles over to go
well yes I know but I mean you know
Israel I don't really I'd be ready when
they just all die that's the reaction
hmm and you know if there is heaven
forbid a war you can imagine what the
BBC is gonna say it's all been a kickoff
when Israel retaliates mmm we don't care
about the Israelis and shelters living
in shelters as they are in the South now
from the missile from Gaza we don't care
about that we don't report that but when
Israel retaliates ah that's the story so
they go may your granddad didn't know I
don't know any we're running out of time
unfortunately so let me ask you a couple
of things before we let you go the first
thing is you can't you've made a career
of writing I would say into the void
between what the kind of media
establishment says and what people think
I think that's that's probably a fair
observation and you've written two books
recently which I know you mentioned
haven't been reviewed and no one seems
to know that they're on sale so tell us
a little bit about that and how that's
happened well for reasons which really
passed my understanding I find it very
difficult to get published in Britain
and have done for about 25 years I was
told 25 years ago that I was blacklisted
by every major publishing house you
would think that I would sell books do
you think I was quite well-known in
Britain you would think the publishers
might like to make some money out of me
they're much more interested in stopping
me from ever having my ideas published
anyway so I've always had difficulty
from you know getting published and my
last two books were published last year
by a small publisher in America
and for various reasons these books have
not been reviewed by any major but by
any mainstream publication in Britain
partly because no one knows that they
exist and partly because one of the ways
that people try and silence me is by
pretending I don't exist they will not
review my books anyway I say there's not
out of any self-pity but just as a
matter of fact but people don't know
these books exist
you can't fight find them in the book
shops the non sale here you can buy them
on Amazon and it's particularly
unfortunate because here in Britain I'm
known and people want to stop me from
writing as it were all being being being
bought and in America people don't exist
I kind of fall between the two still
yeah but I did publish had published
last year two books one of which is a
little memoir that I wrote it's called
guardian angel my journey from leftism
to sanity it's basically what we've been
talking about it's how I changed from
being you know basically the child and
darling of the left to being the
she-devil of the Western Hemisphere and
through the prism of what happened to me
and why I reacted the way I did and it's
got there's quite enough personal stuff
in it as well I kind of tell the story I
I think of what happened to Britain and
the West in my view as a cultural those
sort of things we've been talking about
so that was published last year and I
also published my first novel in which I
was interested to explore in fiction the
themes which have preoccupied me for
some years which is basically again
we've been touching on this but the
novel is about my my antihero
in the novel is a British Jew who
doesn't want to be a Jew and who tries
to pretend that he's not what he is
because he's embarrassed and ashamed of
it and because he doesn't be knowing
about it and through a series of events
he is forced to confront it in a way
which it's not actually
all verbal because it's a conflict which
isn't easily resolved but he comes to
understand that first of all there's
stuff about his identity that is
valuable that he never actually has
taken advantage of and he regrets that
and secondly that he comes to understand
which I believe to be the case that
one's identity is something one can't
run away from that it's it is what you
are what you are and if you run away
from it then then that this either avoid
or there's some sort of reckoning so
it's to do with fractured identity about
a modern British Jew it's about the
persistence the unique persistence of
anti-semitism and is about the pull of
history and it's a small canvas it's
based in Britain today and in modern-day
America and Israel is also the plot is
also set in medieval Britain and in
Holocaust Poland so a small canvas small
feelings that's called the legacy
fascinating well thank you and because
I'd like everyone else I didn't know
they existed until this very calm well
it's you know it's I at this point I
will you know basically get down the
floor and chew the carpet it's quietly
one way but it's very very very annoying
because the people who have read it I
mean taken right there are lots of
people you look on Amazon you'll see
lots of lovely people who've written
very lovely stuff and they say things
like this is a page-turner I couldn't
put it down that I'm thinking why can't
you tell somebody in the media this but
they don't anyway so no one knows it
exists they exist but they do exist and
they came bought on Amazon and it's very
good of you to mention them i'm i'm
trigonometry for now do you know the
existing will be no doubt getting the
books very soon but we've got one more
question for you Melanie before we let
you go which is always what is the one
thing that we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be talking
about haha well it's a something which
you know I mean I'm you know I've
avoided controversy so far am I
the most everyone yeah we've all agreed
with this why is this woman
controversial so there's one topic which
we haven't touched which is like the
killer of killers which is manmade
global warming all right quickly scam
it's a fraud no hoax is the climb and
not getting warmer Mellie the climate
changes that are occurring are in no way
out of the ordinary in respect of the
climate changes fluctuations over the
period of over over over history there
is no evidence whatsoever that anything
out of the ordinary is happening climate
goes up down blah blah this is a very
big subject I imagine
I've written about this since 1988 when
it was invented when I realized
instantly that it was a fraud when I say
a fraud I'm speaking loosely what I
really mean is that it's a theory which
has been supported into an
unchallengeable orthodoxy by a number of
factors first of all you don't get grant
funding as a scientist in these sorts of
climate related areas unless you produce
research which basically upholds a
theory the second thing is that it's
based on a set of Madonn computer
modeling and as I was told right at the
start
climate is one of the most if not the
most complicated set of feedback
mechanisms etc that has you know that
there is in existence and the computer
modeling simply cannot cope with this it
cannot cope with the very the variables
that you have to feed in and so it's
almost inevitable that it will not
produce something which is true as a
means of trying to estimate the future
forecast the future
do it and then the third thing is the
actual frauds the actual frauds of which
there have been a number in which
scientists have simply falsified the
information which has led to a number of
very very distinguished scientists who
have worked for the IPCC as expert
reviewers of the evidence to walk out of
the IPCC when their own research was
being falsified and misrepresented and
when the IPCC was basically producing
false researchers that also I wrote
about this in the world turn upside down
which was published in was it 2010
remember something like that I wrote a
chapter because it seemed to me to feed
into what we've been talking about which
was the gullibility and credulous nests
of a society which tells itself that
it's operating on the basis of
scientific evidence and rationality but
for which this particular issue is to me
an example of how that's been turned on
its head and of course someone like me
comes along and says all this and people
say well she's not even a scientist and
so she's bound to be wrong and 97% of
all scientists but it basically think
that you know something terrible is
happening
well the 97% figure is itself fraudulent
it was based on a Miss a Miss reading of
evidence and there are hundreds of the
most prominent scientists and I've
listed I listed some of them in my book
I've listed them in what I've written
they signed petitions and you know
despite the fact that there is this
penalty on scientists who buck the trend
but it mildly there they are and yet
they're completely ignored completely
ignored BBC issued an edict the science
cannot be gainsaid there is no need in
the interests of balance
it's the BBC it is journalism in the
interests of balance there is known
need to have any alternative view of
climate denier on with a proponent of
manmade apocalyptic climate change so
this is to me just so we were saying
before this is another you know medieval
apocalyptic but this really is
Apocalypse Now it's a medieval
apocalyptic belief system which has
heretics
it has inquisitions it has penalties my
goodness it has penalties I'm just gonna
clarify now right just to simplify this
argument you saying that Greta Thumb bug
is wrong no she's saying she's the
Messiah well we're gonna leave it that
it's the climate change is the thing
that we want to get into and we're gonna
talk to scientists from both sides we
wish we wish we had more time to discuss
it with you but unfortunately our time
is up Mellie
thank you so much for coming on the show
where can people follow you on Twitter
and find out about everything that's
going on with you ah well I have a
website which is easy to remember it's
Melanie Phillips calm on which I post
all my work including blogs and links to
my published articles and links to
appearances on TV and stuff on Twitter
my Twitter handle is at Melanie latest
um and what else my on that's it I think
we'll post all the links and links to
buy your books in the description of the
video and the audio so people can get
that I'm in your debt
no you we are very much in yours as
always follow us at trigger pod on our
social media and we will see you in a
week from now with another brilliant
episode see you next week guys bye bye
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word
[Music]